allez on passe au focus group ça vous a
manqué un focus vraiment d'hypocrisie
mise en valeur au plus un focus group un
peu spécial dans la thématique de la
publicité
j'ai été voir des adolescents ah non
alors à demander pour quelle pub on
n'arrête plus et j'ai passé tout le
monde a évidemment sauf toi non parce
que je les inspire pas je suis désolé
julien courbet et vous souhaitez voir
des réponses un peu particulière alors
déjà bonjour je vais vous montrer des
gens comme dit ce que vous en pensez
et surtout ce qui nous intéresse ce soir
c'est de savoir pour quel produit
cette possibilité pourrait faire de la
publicité ça va aller qu'on regarde mais
il fait rire il est marrant ça bouffe
sinon ouais voilà un peu c'est un peu le
beauf de ttn édition c'est un peu comme
le tendon de sa vie audi des familles
c'est alors on remet dans quelle
publicité
le café parce que c'est quand même un
bel homme enfin pour vous c'est
pour toi les gens sortent progressait
sont obligatoirement des sondés l'homme
ça dépend et toi t'en penses quoi t'as
pas tort c'est ce qu'ils préfèrent faire
de 7 ans à george clooney george clooney
euros visite et jean michel mr des
cuisines
allez on passe à la suivante gilles vers
des jeux sur un coup de coeur de chloé
et à boucher un vampire babouche et
vampires vie sont donc on a trouvé
l'égérie d'halloween
gilles verdez alors gilles verdez on lui
fait de faire de la pub pour qu'elle
produise pourriture prochain parce qu'il
est dans tiens
et puis qu'est-ce qu'on en fait marchât
way direct croire que c'est celui qui
parle comme seul serveur de restaurant
on n'est pas dans un restaurant luxor un
crédit auprès qu'il a la même foi que
stéphane bern un peu facile à une fois
de vieux mais il est jeune et en fait je
trouve que sa voix bas je suis pas 5 h
entre tous ces maximes guennic vous
connaissez maxime gdc non classé c'est
un point fort vous l'attendiez pas non
non
pourquoi mathieu des larmes où aller
voilà les questions qui se posent avec
anton matthieu delormeau
j'aime bien tout temps ils sont vente
oui souvent vous pensez qu'il est
sérieux ou qu'il a et leur avenir
sérieux mais il a fait madmagz madmad
dans les anges télé réalité c'est celui
qui a présenté les ans oui l'équipe a
pas trop denses allawi s'était pas que
l'été patron
qu'est ce que l'on me donne comme
produit à vendre en publicité je le
verrais bien dans la marine cabaret
avec la pluie sur la mer dans les bas
salaires gonflés par des bateaux
conducteur de bateau école de cuisine
pour vendetta vente des classements des
crises est déjà comparé à george clooney
du shampoing je vais l'apprendre
coiffeur non non c'était bon morceau par
morceau que ça n'existe pas et de
michotte bien très bien mais ça ne va
totalement
écoutez je suis allée chez le coiffeur
tout à l'heure c'est totalement raccord
félicitations oui il est payé ou pas à
lens excusez mais vos phrases arrive de
manière aléatoire des fulgurances âme
vient par moments cdg-n ans pas les
fluos alors les filles est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce qui s'est dit oui
moi je sais très bien pour jean michel
maire il a un côté bon père de famille
rassurant à brême et donc comme ça non
mais physiquement comme ça un peu voilà
beau père c'est d'accord sur la voix de
maxime entre maïté et thomas ngijol tout
ça sort effectivement le couvert tout
petit côté un peu un peu vieux dans ce
corps de deux jeunes et pourquoi pas
encore de jeunes chercheurs pour chasser
l'accord canado isabelle moi je fais pas
de commentaires sur les voies des zones
vu la mienne en revanche je me suis
remis cherche trop kiffé plus pervers
pépère que pour pervers alors je suis
désolé j'ai fait ça sur les garçons
parce qu'ils avaient peur que ce soit un
peu désagréable pour les filles
eh bien je voulais voir quand même le
focus group
isabelle est ce que vous la connaissez
[Musique]
oui j'aime bien les bosses bah quoi être
honnête à daniel moreau chez eux
j'avais dans la cuisine enfin remporté
d'étape à spa où les fous rires d'air
mexicains italiens italien est à causse
ont demandé où j'ai le niveau
géographique toi quelle nature ajouter
quelque chose
non toi tu t'en fous de l'année ok on
passe à la personne suivante on peut
dire l avenir d cristina cordula corps
de là c'est la mère de cristina cordula
[Musique]
beaucoup soulignons enfin et on va faire
de la pub pour quoi pour du poulet à la
social
en fait c'est bien ça avait pour idée de
toujours je pense que quatre heures
avant qu'elle n'a pas l'air d'être
convaincu du tout par isabelle
c'est prêt
on dirait blanche et avec son vous allez
et ses dents blanches donc j'ai rien dit
mais on la met dans lequel pour quels
produits à bas pour blanchissement de
blanchiment dentaire
enfin 4 calme toi quand même le cash
allez on passe ça aux clients suivants
méthylation des vrais un bond de 9
ah je pense que ça va lui faire plaisir
ça et s'appelle justin voilà ouais je
pourrais faire de la publicité pourquoi
gainey elisabeth inspirait pas non plus
et daniel non plus joli mais il fallait
commencer par là ouais les dents
blanches abalo repas tout s'est fait
dans vingt quatre à la cacahouète you
can do ré s'est passé à quel moment
c'est pas facile d'être plus est ces
bons seront desservies ça commençait mal
mais après je dis qu'est ce qu'elle est
jolie
pas facile alors que moi il y avait rien
à rattraper non maintenant le problème
si vous retenez que ce qui est négatif
sur les 80 ans et la mère de cristina
cordula que suspendu tous les bas
alors bon et ben vous à retourner dans
la marine